transport ministers meeting in  Luxembourg on Wednesday we'll debate how  to improve rail services in the EU  through a possible market opening for  domestic passenger services and stronger  governance the Commission's proposal to  open domestic rail passenger services to  competition from December 2019 means  that your rail companies would have  equal access to trucks signals and  stations in all EU countries to run  services the council will also seek a  general approach or new rules for access  to the port services market in the EU  and to ensure the financial transparency  of ports on air transport ministers will  examine the progress made on the  implementation of the single European  sky which intends to improve air traffic  management they will also discuss the  future use of drones in the civil  aviation market a highly demanded  development which could also generate  new jobs in the years to come  you